good evening to you first of all why are
you so angry about this I mean clearly
company can't afford it anymore can it
well we think the company can we've
tabled an alternative proposal which we
believe will guarantee defined benefit
pensions going forward and won't cost
the company more than it's currently
paying the reason we're so angry is that
by closing the scheme the company will
devastate the earnings in retirement of
our members so for a typical member aged
about 50 who's expecting to work through
265 the closure of the scheme will mean
a loss of in excess of 4,000 pounds a
year in the income that they can expect
in return although the company said that
those sort of figures only apply to a
very small number of the staff now I
think the company is acknowledged the
the impact will be for most people the
loss of around a third of their income
it's only a tiny minority but do you
think that it is tenable for big
companies to continue with these sort of
pension schemes I mean you you know as
well as I think that almost everyone's
got rid of them because there's such a
burden well people have closed defined
benefit pension schemes and we
acknowledge that there is a problem in
terms of the way those schemes are
funded at the moment in that because of
the economic situation the guilt yields
are very low that's tending to drive an
increase in employer contributions
that's why we've come up with an
alternative plan for a defined benefit
pension scheme which shares the risk
between the employer and the employee
we've worked that through with our
actuarial advisors first actuarial very
well-respected company and we're
confident that we can produce a pension
scheme in which members can enjoy a
similar level of benefits to that they
enjoy in the current scheme without
adding to the costs of pension that raw
man or paying at the moment so what
would it take to avoid industrial action
what it would take is an agreement
industrial action is an imminent I want
to stress that but it is inevitable if
we can't resolve this by agreement this
is a key issue for our members
two-thirds of our members are in this
scheme
the impact as I've said on their
earnings in retirement will be massive
we're determined to get an agreement
with a company which will secure
people's wages in retirement and if we
don't achieve that then we'll be going
into dispute and just just in a sentence
how long are you going to give them to
come up with an agreement before you do
press the button for industrial action
well the scheme the announcement takes
effect in a year's time but we haven't
got a year to resolve this issue we
expect to enter into serious
negotiations with the business and I do
welcome the fact that they've said in
their statement today that they're
committed to reaching the agreement with
the Union we expect to go into intensive
negotiations over the next two to three
months and we're looking for a
resolution in that timeframe all right
thanks very much anyway Alex they're
from the city W you